all right folks uh we start this hour
with the Biden administration's response
to the crisis at our Southern border as
articles of impeachment against DHS
secretary Alejandro myus have been
written up and are released President
Biden says he'd take action now if only
Congress could agree on a spending Bill
to send to his desk Peter duy is back at
the White House this morning and joins
us now with the details Peter and the
move to impeach Alejandro mayorcas isn't
because the border is a mess it's
because he said the border is not a mess
right now and these lawmakers feel like
they have been lied to by him so in the
Articles of impeachment you've got
article one willful and systemic refusal
to comply with the law and then article
two is a breach of public trust the
house Speaker Mike Johnson is saying
this vote to impeach him is going to
happen as soon as possible and speaker
Johnson is one of the most outspoken
voices against the bipartisan Senate
negotiations On the Border but he's
taking income coming speaker Johnson
from the White House before 7 on a
Monday they just pointed out in a new
memo that Johnson once said he only
thinks Congress had the authority to
tighten border security Now Johnson says
President Biden should be doing more but
this Senate Bill everybody's been
talking about that appears like it's
Dead on Arrival is at the heart of
President Biden's claim that he can do
something quickly and on his
own if that bill were the law today I'd
shut down the Border right now and fix
it
quickly a bipartisan bill would be good
for America and help fix our broken
immigration system and allow Speedy
access for those who deserve to be
here it's very unlikely that this
president or any president would ever
say over the last couple years my
immigration policy hasn't worked however
what he's saying now sure is different
than what he was saying four years ago
as a candidate when he said that he
wanted people who were seeking Asylum to
Surge the border and he said said at a
primary debate the quote is We're a
nation who says if you want to flee and
you're freeing oppression you should
come so it's from you should come to I
could shut the border if I want to back
to you right and Peter between there he
also said okay uh don't come but but
that's why we are right where we are
Peter thank you very much yeah it's it's
all no one trusts that President Biden
will ever do this even if he had uh this
new bill thoroughly passed in his hands
why would he crack down now he has to
prove move himself to be able to do it
for example put the remainder Mexico
policy in place finish building the wall
$653 million it's laying there the fence
is actually paid for the contracts are
ready to go you could go and do the
First Nation policy right away the First
Nation you step into is where you apply
and then we'll decide with new rules
when it comes to Asylum you do not need
this bill yet if you show yourself
cracking down this bill would reinforce
it would put pressure on Republicans to
pass it but now the Republicans feel for
with great after they've seen the last 3
years doesn't matter what we give this
guy he's not going to use it after all
when he has some power all he did was
take on Texas and sue them to cut down
the razor wire because he won't finish
the wall to your point I mean this
bill's a red herring okay so let let's
take him at face value you need this
bill you need it so bad because you're
helpless as president well you had
control of Congress unilateral control
of the house and the Senate were
Democrats during the first two years of
your presidency but that's a lie you
don't need Congress to act
you took 94 executive actions in your
first 100 days to go back the Trump era
policies and now you say I would close
the border if I could he has a problem
progressives won't allow that they
panicked when they heard him say that
but his problem is so untable with
mainstream America he must act even if
it means losing some progress sure a
republican from the great state of
Oklahoma James lenford the senator who's
been working on this bill you know he
was on one of the chat shows yesterday
and he was talking about you know there
are all these internet rumors about what
is in the bill uh you know people are
saying a million things they're all
wrong and so he he tried to set the the
record straight he said this bill would
not let 5,000 people in a day it's
actually a shutdown of the border and
everybody actually gets turned around at
the border which sounds good uh he said
the bill gets us to zero illegal
Crossings a day there's no amnesty it
increases detention beds so we can
detain and Deport people quickly it
changes the Asylum process says so
people can get Asylum uh screenings not
in years but within 6 months and returns
them back to their home country on the
spot uh Joe Biden has praised it uh
Donald Trump has said uh I oppose it
because it is a gift to the Democrats
but here's the thing Chris Murphy the uh
Democrat senator from the great state of
uh Connecticut who's working on the bill
said it probably will come up for a vote
this week and we know that the Democrats
control control the Senate so it's going
to pass the question is how many
Republicans are going to be on board and
it's going to be very T they need 60
votes they need six they need 50 votes
51 votes no they need 60 votes to pass
it they're going to need some
Republicans to get on board with this
for for the bill to pass um but here's
the thing I thought just simple majority
um here's the thing on top of that is
sen lford is right and saying before you
start criticizing it we haven't released
it yet right and you can't pass it in 3
days if you actually pass the best Bill
possible in 3 days no Republican should
sign off on that something this
impactful they're going to need some
time to read it and you know it's
interesting because so let's say this
bill comes out and let's say it's decent
in the eyes of the American people you
give the left a talking point when it
doesn't pass because the Talking Point
Joe Biden will use at nauseum from here
until election day is we had meaningful
change we had border change but
Republicans refused to pass it now look
that's Nolan void I don't think this
bill and we haven't seen what's in it
will do anything to stop what's going on
at the border I think hr2 will that's
what Republicans in the House pass that
would restart border uh construction
22,000 minimum border border patrol
agents restart remain in Mexico the
problem is we have a president who's
deciding he does not want to enforce the
laws of Congress the immigration and
nationality Act is on the books he has a
duty to do that without the will you're
not going to solve the right and
ultimately you know as we've heard it's
a it's a presidential election year and
Joe Biden is trying to take this issue
away from the Republicans and while he
might not stop the flow ultimately if if
it does not pass he's going to be able
to say look I pulled out all the stops I
said I was willing to do something but
the Republicans just want this as an
issue I'm Steve duy I'm Brian kilme and
I'm Angley aart and click here to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
to catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling
analysis